amelia what's going on how can i help
hey dr john how are you
i'm doing so good how about you i'm good
okay hey wait hold on you just said you
gave me a long
good which usually is a nice way of
saying not very good at
all i i mean i'm
i'm struggling if i'm being honest there
we go all right we tell the truth on
this show amelia
all right so hey what's up so
i am a
wife a mom of two um
a six-year-old and a two-year-old and
i am a neonatal nurse
oh honey amelia
that's a lot i don't even know why
you're calling that's a lot
um so i absolutely love
my job um i
i feel like it is where
i am meant to be it's my
it's my passion it's my work um
it's um
but also so it's a mom right so i guess
that's where my struggle
is is i feel like i'm
where i'm supposed to be and what i'm
supposed to be doing
but i don't want my kids and my family
to suffer
um based on the choices of my career
um and i'm just i guess i'm just
struggling with finding a balance
between it all
um and that struggle between
you know i'm i'm doing what i know i'm
supposed to be doing like
it feels right i'm happy i'm
um but then you know
my kids aren't in bed at you know 8 30
and they're
you know there's not really a set
schedule
i guess that's the best way to put it um
and so um i guess to complicate things
my six-year-old has recently been
diagnosed with adhd
um and so just making sure that he has
that balance
and that he feels that you know mom and
dad are here for them
no matter what um how's your no
how's your how's your marriage
our marriage is great um what does that
mean um
what is great so i have full support
from my husband
um he wants to
you know make sure that i'm happy and
that um
you know he's fully supportive of
me working and
doing what we've both worked so hard for
to get to this point i mean we have
good communication we are working on
that but i do feel like that has
improved
um we are seeing a actual counselor
um since my son was diagnosed we want it
to be on the same page as far as
how we handle different situations and
scenarios and things like that so i feel
like
the openness is there and he has long
work hours as well and he's a
an emergency veterinarian so he also has
long hours and hard days
but i do feel like that communication's
there i feel like
i can trust him he is my best friend
like he's the one that i
that i want to do life with um so
i know so
there's a lot here give me a specific
question how can i help you
um i guess just how do i
how do i take the negativity from
coming in from the outside of saying
that
i guess from family members that mean
well
um saying that you know my children are
suffering because they're
the hours that my husband and i work um
you know having the
um
i i'm sorry no it's okay so let me do
this i'm gonna start
walking this back and you feel free to
cut me off and jump in at any time
okay sure and my promise to you
as a fellow houstonian even if you were
from
mars i would be honest with you is i'm
going to tell you the truth the truth
and nothing but the truth
so help me god okay um
your life sounds chaotic is that a good
word
that's pretty accurate okay it's not a
bad thing it just sounds like an
is right and it would be chaotic because
you have a six and a two-year-old just
be on just because of that right six and
two-year-olds are a lot they're all over
the place
and they're fun and beautiful and
wonderful and oh my gosh if i can't
sleep a whole night right so they're all
of it right all the same time
right that's number one number two
i've got two people deeply committed to
traumatic professions
who love one another and are trying to
make that work okay
yes sir and when you are a don't say sir
so y'all both deal in trauma every day
people come to you in their worst
moments and say please
help me please save my baby
please save my um this
animal that this pet of mine that has
this is all i've got
right and that is a lot every day
and y'all i know you all know that but
sometimes it helps for somebody else to
say it out loud
y'all deal in other people's hurt
okay right and what people come to you
and say
everything in my world is dark please
turn the light on somehow some way
right and then you've got
so you got two little kids you got chaos
no matter what you got two people who
deal in trauma
every day right
and then you are trying to make all this
work at all the same time
and then somebody comes and drops
something in your lap that says hey your
six-year-old
has a chaos connection
learning disorder which is adhd which is
a
another way to frame it and i get a lot
of grief for it and i don't care
um i'm a card-carrying member i'm off
the chart by the way
like um i i on the scoring it's comical
okay so the hard reality is
if we look at adhd as a connection issue
as a
response to chaos a learned response to
chaos
and also the nonsensical educational
environment some of our kids are forced
into
right then you you start to reverse
engineer your life
and it gets hard and then people start
throwing their little comment grenades
at you
right um they start telling you things
that cut you right into your soul as
though they're helping and they're not
because these are all things that you
know
right and so here's what i'm gonna super
strong recommend you do okay
what i'm telling you right now is you
are on a recipe for
complete and total burnout and i think
probably both of you are you and your
husband
and the problem with the burnout is you
don't know where it's going to land
whether it's going to be relational
burnout
whether it's going to be professional
burnout whether it's going to be burned
out on those kids
okay and i'm telling you that twofold
number one
i have lived the life you were talking
about right now okay
with the only difference is my wife
didn't work in trauma she was a
professor
she didn't work a sh i didn't have two
rows or two of us working in trauma just
one of us okay
so here's my recommendation are you
ready this is the
prescription from a non-medical guy you
ready
yeah i want you and to start in reverse
order
none of this works none of it
unless you and your husband prioritize
your marriage number one above your kids
above your work above all of it
okay okay and so that starts with y'all
two getting together
and being real vulnerable with each
other being
really direct letting him know
what you need from him what you need
just
period letting him tell you what he
needs
what are things that y'all can do for
one another to help you guys be whole
because you'll have to be whole because
you're dealing with so much secondary
traumatic stress
and you can only repel off and hold
another mom whose baby's in nicu
you can only repel off and hold another
baby and another baby and another baby
when you are fully anchored in okay
um so number one you've got to
give him permission to hold you
accountable to whatever you all agree to
you're going to have to let him um speak
into your life and you're
he's going to let you speak into his
life and what does that look like that
means y'all can have to be honest about
what you eat
how much y'all move and exercise are
y'all getting sleep are y'all taking
care of yourselves
are you putting your oxygen mask on
first to beat an old metaphor to death
right only then can you then
focus on those two beautiful angels that
you brought into the world
and they come next right what are the
boundaries with kids what are the ways
that mom and dad are dealing with our
secondary traumatic stress
i'm so glad to hear you all say hey we
just got some new information our kids
got adhd so we're gonna go to counseling
to make sure we have the tools to
connect with one another we're on the
same page that's so awesome amelia
that that was your default good for you
but
what is the way we're going to be
connected with these kids
and then and only then does
our professional life come after that
okay
and you said something that i wrote down
here
we worked so hard to get somewhere
and you got there and i want to tell you
i've done research
i've met with i can't even tell you how
many doctors
lawyers fancy pants preachers
college presidents senior staff at
universities across the country
and i can't tell you how many times i've
heard the line
i worked so hard to get here and then
they have to ask themselves
was it worth it i worked so hard to get
here but i just want to play with my kid
i worked so hard to get here but i never
see my wife i work so hard to get here
and fill in the blank
and you can all every time you can i say
the following words you don't have to
keep doing this job and you can almost
see their shoulders just drop
as they never even considered that or
they will say
really quickly no no i want to do this
job and i love it when they say that too
because now i know what's important
right your marriage your kids
your job but we're going to do it in
that order
and we're going to not give on these
priorities that we say we're not going
to give on and then we know we're in it
right
and that way when you come home
exhausted you can text your husband at
four o'clock in the afternoon
and say i'm having a day and it's
my ranking score is a seven and he knows
all right i got dinner tonight
i got kids bath tonight and i'm all in
or you can text him and say today was a
two and he's like
sweet she's got dinner i've got one kid
she's got the other we're gonna divide
and conquer whatever system y'all come
up with
but it's gotta go in that order does
that make sense
yes is that frustrating to hear
or is it a relief to hear
um i think it's what i've been telling
myself
okay um i guess
um and i think that's a struggle
as i know where the priority should be
um
and um
i guess it's just it's a struggle of
finding what's the right answer
because you know here's the writing yes
the hours the right answers
your relationship and your kids and your
work in that order
because one doesn't work without the
other if you were single
yeah dude you were all in on this nike
gig and i would still be telling you you
got to prioritize
you your psychological and spiritual
mental health
above the nike job because you're no
good to those kids if you're fried and
burnt out
you're no good to those mothers and
fathers who are so desperately clinging
on to
every last shred of hope you're no good
to them
if you're not good at if you're not
whole at home right
and if you were a single mom i would
tell you your health comes first your
brain and your heart come first
those kids come second work comes third
and you tethered yourself to a guy that
sounds like he's a great guy
he's a good man he's deals with trauma
for a living he helps other people he
loves you he loves your kids
and so he comes first and then when
you're tethered in there then you can
anchor off and be the mom and dad that
you all are going to be
that you know you've got that picture in
your head what that's going to look like
and then and only then can you be the
trauma nurse
that those families desperately need you
to be
that what i want to give you permission
is just to drop your shoulders
and go we got a lot going on and it may
be
that for this season he doesn't work
overnight shifts
because you got a six and a two year old
and
maybe for the next three years
he is just doing the day shift
and he just he goes off call and it's
gonna hammer y'all financially and it
sucks
but those kids are worth the time
or maybe for the next two years you
don't work night shifts you work day
shifts and you're not
doing weekend plugs whatever that looks
like but give yourselves permission to
go in that order
most couples try to reverse engineer it
how many hours can we
shave off and not have to do this i want
you all to start the other way
i love you so much
and here's what you bring to me you
don't even know what you bring to me how
much i love
and here's what i desperately need from
you
what can i help with you so that you and
i can work together
and then man what do we want our kids
worlds to look like what do we
what kind of picture do we want to what
we want home to look like
and you said it best man kids are
routine
sponges bedtimes every night
at this time even if it cuts into mom
and dad time they're gonna get their
bedtime here
they're gonna eat here they're gonna
we're gonna all get up together or
i'm gonna go do my morning routine dad's
gonna do wake ups on
this week and i'm gonna flip it whatever
that looks like but you're gonna
map that out and then you'll figure out
the work stuff later
and if you're an awesome nike nurse i
guarantee you are
and your work doesn't accommodate that
there's a hundred different places in
houston texas where you can go be an iq
nurse
there just is and if your husband's
practice says no bro you
you gotta do there's a hundred there's a
thousand places in
in houston where he can go be an awesome
vet with that kind of expertise and that
kind of experience and the kind of
compassionate heart that he has
so you're not locked in you just gotta
go in the right order
i am so proud of you as a couple i'm
proud of you emilia
for thinking through this i'm so
grateful that there are
incredible smart brilliant compassionate
women like you out there taking care of
these babies
taking care of these families who are
have a baby who are struggling
every moment of their life has been
rocked upside down so glad you're doing
this
and i'm so glad you're a mom who loves
your kids and then you're a wife who
loves her husband
and also don't forget you got a six and
a year old everything feels like the end
of time when you have a six and a two
year old
there should be a youtube series just
for parents of six and two-year-olds
called it gets better
i know there's a couple of different
series it gets better i'm telling you
you got a six and two-year-old it gets
better
it does it does it does